hey guys what's going on this week in
Bitcoin there's pretty much like two
things that really matter the first is
that Bitcoin officially hit less
volatility than the S P 500 and NASDAQ
now this happened before back in 2020
but the fact that everyone has been
talking about bitcoin's volatility
Bitcoin can't be used as a currency
bitcoin's not a good investment all of
the critics they keep pointing to
volatility but now both stock indexes
the NASDAQ and the S P 500 are more
volatile than Bitcoin now of course
these things will go back and forth over
time so you shouldn't celebrate but it
is an important detail to understand
that Bitcoin is not always more volatile
than other assets in fact given the
current macro environment and the FED
policy that's been displayed over the
last year Bitcoin has held up reasonably
well in the last couple of weeks we've
seen foreign currencies around the world
sell off against the US dollar but
Bitcoin continues to hold stronger in
the 19 to 20 000 range it's fascinating
to see less volatility than even the
stock market and so it'll be worth
paying attention to to see how we close
out the year what will bitcoin's
volatility look like and what will other
assets both stocks bonds Commodities
real estate and others now the second
big story this week was the fact that
Walmart's CTO came out and said that
crypto was going to be a big part of the
way that various customers would
actually buy goods and services in the
future now the Walmart CTO obviously
paying attention to what technologies
are out there what Innovations could
they possibly go ahead and embrace and
the fact that it's now calling out
crypto in general but probably more
specifically Bitcoin as a payment
Network or something like a stable coin
being used by consumers now numbering in
the hundreds of millions of people
around the world that hold these assets
that signals that these big retailers
these big e-commerce companies they are
not going to get left behind so whether
it's bitcoin's volatility or it is
something like the Walmart CTO coming
out and talking about these Technologies
being used by consumers there's a lot to
continue to pay attention to Bear
markets Hotel people get bored sometimes
there's even folks who say it's over but
I continue to be high conviction and I
continue to see number of signs in the
market that show that we are actually
going to end up better off on the other
side now don't forget these updates are
brought to you by FTX you can go ahead
and check them out in the link in the
description FTX has fees sometimes as
much as 85 cheaper than their
competitors they also introduce digital
stock trading go check that out as well
click on the link to support us and I'll
see you all next Saturday